as questions loom over the safety of
surgical mesh in the UK we've come to
Cincinnati in the United States dr.
Krista Armit is one of the world's
leading experts in plastic materials
recently his expertise been used in
class action against vaginal mesh
manufacturers
he's helped 9,000 women settle out of
court by arguing that the plastic in the
controversial implants is not safe there
are two main reasons why any true
plastic material expert would tell you
in five minutes for you know just
obviously that this is a bad material
one is it's oxidatively unstable and
that just means like an apple it's
attacked by air so it's not going to
last long enough in the body so that's a
that's a knock out criteria right there
because it's just gonna fail it's gonna
go brittle and fall into pieces and the
second thing is it's not biocompatible
so when you put it in the body all of
your body tries to react it's it's like
having a splinter your body says hey
there's a foreign object in here let's
get this out and it starts using all
these different mechanisms to attack
that thing and that causes inflammation
and it can even lead to reactions and
pain polypropylene mesh has been
commonly used to treat incontinence and
prolapse in women for decades and is
used in hernia repair you really see
can't neither the jagged edges you can
they're remarkably jagged and you feel
it with your fingers people react
differently to mesh as no immune system
is the same but there's also a notable
lack of studies looking into the problem
while the surgery can be successful it
can also cause life-changing
complications including chronic pain if
you had a nerve that had grown through
there that would be squashed and then
you'd feel that dr. Krista Armit
believes that essentially mesh degrades
in the body I see an absolute disregard
for proper testing so the testing done
on this is way less than you would see
even on a vacuum cleaner or a washing
machine or a dishwasher and or any of
those materials
it's shocking I've never seen anything
like it in my career for these women
permanently injured by mesh implants the
words of dr. Armit aren't surprising but
they're still hard to hear you're in so
much pain but you don't know why it's
when you start out it's just really hard
you have to really trust yourself and
then when you find out the true
it's almost more traumatizing it's great
to hear somebody admitting it and not
differentiating between the different
meshes actually saying that the material
itself the polypropylene is the problem
for John or mesh operations to treating
consonants are suspended in the UK
pending the results of an independent
review into the procedures safety
dr. Vincent argent has one expert who's
contributed to the review he warned
about the risks of mesh when it was
first introduced in the late 1990s but
was ignored the problem with mesh is the
physical chemical changes which he
undergoes happened over many many years
as we see now and that could have been
predicted from studies way back in the
60s and 70s which showed that
polypropylene mesh is inherently
unstable it shouldn't be used in routine
clinical practice and so there are more
clinical trials and more research into
the stability of the mesh if it was
introduced now I don't think it would
the manufacturers of mesh in the UK deny
that mesh is unstable Boston Scientific
told Sky News we are dedicated to using
quality materials in all of our medical
products and we have done extensive
testing to establish the safety of our
materials polypropylene is long studied
and well supported as a material for use
in mesh which has been used in millions
of patients and by surgeons worldwide
but dr. de armas says his research shows
otherwise
I would say there's no place for
polypropylene it's has no chance to last
long enough in the body and it creates
an immune response which is unacceptable
the data is there the arguments are
absolutely clear any true expert in
plastics will tell you this is an
unsuitable material and yet actions not
being taken as quickly as it should be
I'd be reporting on vaginal mesh for
four years and this is the first time
we've been able to find out more about
the material itself if doctor to arm it
is right and polypropylene isn't safe
this could have huge consequences we've
shared his evidence with the review team
here in the UK who will decide if the
journal mesh impacts will again be
since surgery or be banned indefinitely
Charlotte Lomas Sky News